empathy is simply recognizing someone's
Human Condition
so I'll give you an example in business
here's a fairly common
uh scenario
you walk into someone's office and you
say your numbers are down for the third
quarter in a row
we've had this conversation before
if you don't pick up your numbers in the
fourth quarter I don't know what's going
to happen
that's fairly common
now let's Infuse empathy
you walk into their office and say you
know your numbers are down for the third
quarter in a row
we've had this conversation before
I'm worried about you what's going on
are you okay
that's empathy
and when someone feels like you care
about them as a human being not just as
a set of numbers on a spreadsheet
the result is they will give you Blood
Sweat and Tears for many years to come
that's what empathy is all about it's
simply recognizing that somebody is more
than simply the job they do and that's
what you're supposed to be doing with
your clients they're more than a bank
account they're more than a financial
ambition
they have dreams and insecurities they
have families they have self-image it's
for us to understand all of that